next week will it be full steam ahead to
improve passenger rail services MEP is
also contain either crackdown on tax
avoidance and let's take you obscurity
in defense to infinity and beyond
welcome to the agenda public transport
delays can be rather taxing if there's
some irony bad from the fact that a deal
to open up railway networks across
Europe is not quite on track a more
competitive rail network is a great idea
in theory but putting into practice is
another issue basic such as rail
infrastructure have long been considered
and natural national monopolies not all
EU countries are gung-ho about
liberalizing their rail networks to EU
wide competition and they want long
transition periods for the rules to take
effect many member states also want to
maintain the right to directly award
public service contracts so cannon tea
will be struck a final trial of between
the Parliament Member States and the
Commission takes place on Tuesday the
Panama papers leak is the latest scandal
that throws a spotlight on aggressive
tax avoidance and no doubt provides
further fuel for Parliament Special
Committee on tax to call for legislative
change to taxation laws Monday will see
a meeting with representatives of
national parliaments to see whether
greater institutional oversight could
help crack down on tax evaders
the recently unveiled anti tax avoidance
package will also be on the agenda for
discussion
Kedar security air and air be governed
in space satellite systems already
provide critical information for
civilian and military purposes plans
aimed promotes EU space programs like
Galileo a satellite navigation system
and Copernicus an early warning system
and have them fully operational and
provide fair long-term finance the
Foreign Affairs Committee votes on their
initiative on Tuesday morning and now
with an even brief
Parliament's new car emission inquiry
committee set up in the wake of the VW
emission scandal behold their first
hearing late
Tuesday evening do you have the right
skills for the new era of digital
technology EU commissioners Marianne
Tyson and t-bone Alexis will discuss a
new skills agenda with MEP s
discrimination against women persists in
the workplace in higher education and
when they have families any P's vote on
a draft report to reverse the trend a
new four-year deal with the Islamic
Republic of Mauritania to allow you
vessels to continue to fish in their
waters is in the pipeline Parliament's
fisheries committee votes on the
proposal on Tuesday and also look at the
president of Euro Chester will be at the
Parliament next week and finally the
oneworld Human Rights Film Festival
kicks off in Brussels on Tuesday
selected films can be watched with right
here at the Parliament or at various
spots across city workshops all to be
held with previous Sakharov Prize
laureates see the website for further
details and that's all we have this
agender take care and enjoyed a week